über einen twitter trend reden der in
letzter zeit auf twitter sehr populär
geworden ist und zwar heißt er wie folgt
maxxx mega projekt reloaded
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer runde pad
wars hier auf meinem kanal zusammen mit
maxl kran crafter hey hey erstmal das
alles gute zu deinem bei mir ist alles
klar bei dir sollte noch mehr als klar
sein weil du heute 100 abonnenten
erreicht hast als stimmt ihr ich freue
mich auf jeden fall riesig darüber wenn
ihr das special sehen wollt könnt ihr
ganz einfach auf max kanal gehen da hat
er sonst so ein bisschen was hochgeladen
dazu wie der gründer dieses für die
stadt gar nicht ach so ja bei mir zwar
noch ein bisschen gelegt habe und keine
blöcke bekommen wir haben uns allerdings
anderen grund für dieses video überlegt
und zwar wollten wir ein wenig über
einen twitter trend reden der in letzter
zeit auf twitter sehr populär geworden
ist und zwar heißt er wie folgt max
hashtag megaprojekt reloaded
wir haben auch schon ein paar andere
youtuber videos drüber gemacht unter
anderem ich habe das gestern schon
direkt aufgefasst und ich glaube sie man
hat auch schon wieder drüber gemacht
aber es ist wirklich ein cooles thema
deshalb sprechen erst bei luca noch mal
an und zwar hat er eine zuschauerin so
eine community aktion ins leben gerufen
über twitter weil das eigentlich ganz
ganz gut geht also darüber könnt ihr am
meisten kontakt zu uns haben weil wird
also ich zum beispiel
für mich gesagt geh am meisten wirklich
bei twitter auf die leute einmal
facebook gar nicht bei instagram geht's
schlecht weil man da so schlecht
scrollen kann und da einfach 100 prozent
von der werbung ist aber bei twitter
kann man halt echt über hashtags und so
ganz gut kontakt aufnehmen was hat sie
da gemacht ihr sie hat einfach ein tweet
verpasst verfasst irgendwie ich habe den
genauen tweet nicht vor augen aber
irgendwie sowas wie wär's denn mal mit
hashtag megaprojekt reloaded und dann
haben ihre twitter-follower die
wahrscheinlich auch videos gucken und so
haben sich eine krasse sache
und dann haben halt andere leute das
hashtag verwendet und das ging dann so
weit dass irgendwas youtuber erreicht
hat also die dann die dann darauf
reagiert haben und auch das hashtag
geschrieben haben und dadurch hat sich
das halt verbreitet hier ein lauffeuer
und soll sich das entwickelt und dann
hatten irgendwann auch die youtuber
davon ahnung und das ist sogar in die
trends gelangt also in die
deutschlandweiten trend zwar vor glaube
ich irgendwie sami slimani der da gerade
irgendwie so ein frage antwort video
gemacht hat oder so also da waren als er
hat auf jeden fall so ein paar
dinge erreicht die otto ist man schon
sein schwert zugeworfen
wundervoll dank der spitze jetzt hat auf
jeden fall so ein paar dimension
erreicht dass man gar nicht gedacht
hätte sage ich mal
ich will mir auch noch ein paar blöcke
und ich habe von meinem video die ganze
geschichte ist einfach echt super cool
finde dass die community ja sich
sozusagen selbstständig gemacht und
einfach dass ich sag mal einfordert
worauf sie lust hat riesig über twitter
dass kunst geben worauf sie bekam
richtig ja also so sollte es auch sein
ich mein mann macht ja die videos für
die community und wenn die community und
etwas besonderes will dann sollte es
einfach ja soll es einfach sagen und so
war das dann auf jeden fall also die
haben dann einfach ein hersteller die
haben irgendwie geschrieben blablabla
wie wäre es denn eigentlich mal mit mega
truck tour lautet das war ein ganz cool
megaprojekt und fieber waren ja bisher
die projekte die am meisten gefeiert
wurden mega projekt würde ich sagen noch
mehr weil da ganz viele storys mit
verbunden wie zum beispiel dass da leute
auf einmal aus der stadt raus sind das
leute sich gar nicht mit technik befasst
haben die anderen wiederum viel viel
mehr
hier war der messe role player megapark
war dieses projekt was so komplett diese
ganze verbundenheit auch junge lena dank
hab ich dachte hat schon du warst das
war so ein grüner bei uns aber wir sind
ja selber team grün wir waren noch für
einige zeit team gelb deswegen ein
bisschen verwirrt das ist halt das
projekt was quasi alles ins leben
gerufen hat das ist ganz cool
und deswegen haben wir uns gedacht wir
machen darüber mal ein video
warteschleife zwei haltbarkeit paket das
heißt ich muss mich beim lesen
konzentrieren wenn man auf jeden fall
gedacht dass wir darüber einfach so ein
kleines video machen das ganze mal
aufpassen wie wir darüber denken ob so
was möglich sei
umzusetzen und so ein paar andere dinge
und dann würde ich erst mal sagen was
hältst du davon weil du hattest ja dazu
auch schon ein video gemacht
also ich hab ich fände es auf jeden fall
echt hammer wenn das umgesetzt wird
einmal wenn man halt auf die community
hat und den wünschen von ihnen nachgeht
und sowas und andererseits weil es
einfach ein geiles projekt war weil das
ist ja die projekte die so bisher ja
statt von haben waren ja alle eigentlich
grundsätzlich anders als
und war hero all diese sachen wahlrecht
komplett unterschiedlich und am besten
mache ja ich bin ich bin tot
ich hatte so viele geile sachen dabei
und danach zum reden und dann konnte ich
nicht sagen was ich vor acht wollte ganz
schnell eine scheiße ich hatte acht ich
habe acht gold ich hatte ich hatte so
tränke dabei und alles möglich mit
schnelligkeit und heilung und wollte zur
blauen beeren und die fertig machen um
an ein regal
also was wolltest du sagen du bist doch
gar kein bisschen leise stellt man ganz
ganz geschmissen lauter noch ich kann
ein bisschen näher ans mikro hergibt
dann ja und zwar ich finde es einfach
krass findet wenn es umgesetzt wird es
muss ja nicht sofort passieren sind
sicher andere dinge auch geplant aber
wenn das irgendwann umgesetzt wird wenn
ich das einfach echt cool weil ich das
megaprojekt gefeiert hat feed the beast
a cool wenn alle leute mit ihren
jetpacks rom geflogen sind und so was
war einfach war echt cool und ja also
ich würd feiern wie wir es bei dir ja
also man muss ja sagen es existiert
mittlerweile schon eine gruppe bei skype
so ein paar leute drin sind oder
eigentlich alle drin sind die auch ein
megaprojekt dabei waren ich weiß nicht
ob ich das falsch deshalb hab ich kann
es einfach mal sagen wo schon so ein
paar dinge besprochen wurden allerdings
wird er dann auch festgehalten
das ganze ist eine richtig coole idee es
ist cool dass ihr das ins leben gerufen
habt aber sowas muss lange geplant
werden vor allem man kann nicht einfach
sagen wie bei mick damals ja wir machen
drauflos wir haben auch im mega projekt
immer mal ab und anderen noch neue
regeln dazu genommen und alles mögliche
noch gemacht und das projekt war sie mit
der dauer des projektes erst zu diesem
projekt gemacht zudem ist geworden ist
ich hoffe ich habe das jetzt irgendwie
richtig gesagt und so was dauert halt
immer noch so eine menschenkette hast du
kannst du ihm brüstung erwarte ich von
menschen hier in dsds drin ist drin luca
nehmen sie die einfach hier in der kiste
ich habe gott selber schon welche
gemacht keine drin und das noch zwei
kisten
man hat nur eine woche später spitze
nicht aber ich hab selber tobacco du
musst dann kriegt man hört sich gar
nicht ich hab locke man kann sie einfach
drüber bauen
mir jedenfalls haben wir uns dann
gedacht dass wir darüber auch mal drin
also ich muss echt hätte ich mal sagen
ich bin so ein talent bis runter
gefallen ja aber der weg da in den
willst du gar nicht wissen ich bin
irgendwie auf dem blog ausgerutscht das
passt also ich weiß nicht ich fans auf
jeden fall richtig cool wenn sowas ins
leben gerufen werden würde tun und ich
hatte auch bock auf sowas aber es muss
halt wirklich geplant werden und ich
habe zurzeit was mich angeht so ein paar
andere dinge noch geplant also bleibt
skeptisch und danach wieder skeptisch
minecraft 3 kommt dann auch noch raus
und so ein paar ganz viele andere sachen
kommen da auf uns zu ich habe einfach
acht rückstoß stärker gemacht ich leider
hengst und ich mache ich jetzt doch
endlich mal das ist ja nicht mehr zeit
nicht zu schaffen so rittner
ich bin ich jetzt verfügbar spitzen
dingen kann ein lauter machen
okay okay wir wurden sondern ein paar
programme wussten ja ich komme jetzt
auch überlassen einfach auf dem geld
gehen jetzt warte ich habe gerade noch
gold geholt für dich du hast gar keine
rüstung bruder genau sicher irgendwas an
bevor du auf jemand drauf geschickt die
schießen auf uns also auf mich zumindest
hier entlang gelaufen bin
aber hast du schon echt gut gemacht hier
eingebaut ist unser wetter irgendwie
beschützt so erstmal den getötet und ich
weiß nicht sollten verdammt erst mal
einer mit rüstung an zu uns jeder steht
hier nur markt regelt ist okay gut ich
kann unser bett bisschen mit besserung
junge er kommt damit übelster rüstung
alter richtiger panzer man aber die welt
von unten sieht auch ganz gut aus
eigentlich könnten passt unser mit
eingebaut wir müssen die positiven dinge
unser weg gerade ein
mit ein bisschen besseren stein also ich
habe 13 du bist ja so ein hengst
dankeschön schon immer und schwächen
dann hole ich mir noch ein
boros platte wir können wir noch eine
besserung dafür bräuchte also wenn
jemand ich glaube kann ich mir nicht
noch damit seinen erfrierung scrollen
jeder kostet 7 eisen alter erfrierung
strank schnelligkeit er sieht aber mit
rico referieren
bald einmal kostet empfehlungs dank
junge ich weiß nicht hinter dem ausbau
reisen und masse alter einfach mal 22
eisen geholt also du bist damit die mal
so oft traf ich hole mir noch so ein
paar sachen und dann mache ich mich
selber zum paradies oder älter wenn man
fast alles von selber gekauft aber gold
hast du gar keinen oder wenig habe 740
silber pack die man die kiste also
soviel kannst du ihn nicht geworden war
steht als er ist mac mich über die ganze
karte wer eine tiefe reicht aber zu
leben erschwert ist ist noch weg doch
damit hat er mich ziemlich weggewischt
ok davon kann ich noch meinen nehmen von
den knüppeln oder als hätte ich mir noch
jedem geile schwerter drei gold wird
costas alter oder ellenbogen so ich habe
jetzt noch hier in den trakt junge team
gehört gab es ziemlich krass die mitte
also das ist echt heftig wie die der
unter kontrolle haben
hast du noch rüstung werde ich um eben
ganz kurzfristigen einfach m wollte
schon rot kommt uns ja ich hole jetzt
rüstung dann gehen wir einfach auch mal
hin oder ja aber der typ hat einen bogen
halten hält ist die sache ich vollidiot
ich habe mein ganzes elementar von mit
lederhosen gemacht überhaupt wer hier
ist ein richtiger bayer
ich bin sogar wissen dabei in münchen
fan oder halb so ich kenne natürlich
geht's in die mitte doch nicht da nicht
dann nicht immer etwas essen moment
moment wartet die andere hälfte von mir
fern wenn ich von bayern familie was
sonst arminia so ich trinke jetzt eben
ein schnelligkeit rang drei mit
schnelligkeit und jetzt jetzt rasch in
die mitte älter ok pass auf dass du dich
nicht erwischen lässt von denen bist du
bist in der mitte eines tot aber nur
einer stelle inmitten der mitte zusammen
ich habe mich hat noch einen schwierigen
start mit der gespannten lage durch mal
ich bin auch wirklich okay ich kommen
kaum hinterher ich komm hinterher haben
auf jeden fall unseren weg ein bisschen
gefestigt ist klebt auch auf team blau
macht denn jemand was gegen team blau
alter alter junge dieser einen damit ist
echt das ist nicht mehr normal was er
bisher was hat dem abgeteilter gericht
nicht viel zeug richtig gutes zeug ich
gehe daher direkt in ihr die haben auch
das komplette gold alter das ist richtig
wir die mitte gehört jetzt übrigens uns
ja das ist meist
natürlich weiß ich hab den ich habe den
op typen der alles gold von denen hatte
die haben jetzt nichts mehr
wie viel hast du ihr wert ist kaputt
viele geld dazu man kann es nicht
aufheben das gold verdienen also wenn
ich sterben dann ist es halt werk
einfach weitere junge dass du bist du
wurdest du bist du ich hab ja tibet
zerstörten wenn die jetzt einmal runter
fallen oder solange es vorbei mit ihm
zusammen das gold momentan ja um wieder
jetzt können auch wieder ein bisschen
quatschen spannung hier mal ganz kurz
weg es wäre auf jeden fall geil und ihr
was ihr eventueller machen könnte wäre
ich habe sieben gold dann wenn ihr ideen
habt für mega fraktur leute die man
megaprojekt eventuell noch besser machen
könnte aber film mord pack oder englisch
ist weil wir sind da so ein bisschen
also ich fände es auf jeden fall cool
dann könnte uns das einfach mal
schreiben also wir haben ja alle youtube
kommentare und die dürfte auch fleißig
ausnutzt und wenn ihr der bock habt ich
gebe bringt erstmals eisen schwert mit
na ja also auf jeden fall wenn man so
zurück denkt ein bisschen strengeres
regelwerk auf jeden fall nicht weiter
also man das team rot wurde vernichtet
sehr schön wachs ich bringe ich komme
damit dann gehe ich den ein schwert das
was zu essen für mich ich kann ja ich
kann schnell umdrehen da was kaufen dann
mach das mal eben so mache ich ja so als
wäre auf jeden fall eine gute sache wenn
man sich irgendwo ein paar feinheiten
überlegt wie man es besser macht
dann wäre es auf jeden fall echten
projekt mit potenzial würde ich sagen ja
man muss das ganze halt wirklich
geplante asyl dürft jetzt halt nicht
denken
ja wir hatten es einmal in den trends
ist kommt sofort projekt ich kann dort
nicht zurück laufen weil ich sehe dass
dieser team blau typ dahinter mit dem
bogen steht aber wir wollen dranbleiben
alter damit wir gehen einfach auf die
bleibt einfach mehr mittel ich habe
schon zehn gold wieder g9 sicherlich
hast du schon rüstung eigentlich ja
komplett also auch diese diese leder
sache ja genau ich brauche halt nur was
zu essen relativ häufig einen schnellen
kaffee bringt ja ich komme die mittel
ich hab einen stack gebratenes fleisch
ich habe 13 geholt jetzt hätte ich alle
dann kommen sie zu sehr um hier wollen
wir was kräften willkommen einfach
hierher gibt erstmals essen einfach
überlaufen oder soll ich mir noch im
bogen ja mal mit drogen duell yahoo
kaufte ihn die hier aber bei den roten
nicht hinter dir deinen chef max weil
ich nicht dass hier untergeschoss werd
ich beim ersten bisschen selber holen
dann kommt es noch speed record zu
kaufen kommt danach zu team rot rot hat
ja gar keine pace gehabt die hatten
nichts aber die hatten die ganze die
halt die mitte besetzt weil dieser einen
op typen hatten brauchst du auch ein
bogen oder hast du schon ein
ich habe noch nichts also ich hab nicht
mal ein schwert tragen
ich habe jetzt einmal mehr ließ den
silber geholt und kauf mir davon die
sache natürlich man bogen hin und du
hast hast du eine spitzhacke ich habe
dir gott die sachen geschmissen
nein das dann so dankeschön feier und
für den bogen würde ich sagen es wie
tränke noch oder gib mir mal ein spiel
noch mit sehenswerten galerien
aufgeklebt mir fehlen noch zwei eisen
ich habe gar keinen drang eigentlich
cool dann würde ich sagen legen wir los
oder lego ist also um das man die mega
backup zu stehen das ist eine richtig
geile idee ich finde es auch ein ein
dickes lob an euch dass ihr das
hingekriegt hat von alleine so in die
indy trend zu bekommen vor allem es war
ja relativ lange darin lockern tag lang
24 schon in den deutschlandtrend
und nur weil es von usern ins leben
gerufen wurde und dann da sieht man
einfach wieder dass twitter somit das
geilste netzwerk ist weil darüber könnt
ihr uns kontaktieren könnte mit uns
kontakt aufnehmen könnt ideen verbreiten
und so was alles also das ist eigentlich
richtig gut dafür gemacht deswegen will
ich sein macht euch allen
twitter-account als fazit also wenn ihr
wollt könnt ihr gerne machen könnte
damit darüber diskutieren aber so kann
man halt ideen entwickeln und das ist
auf jeden fall richtig cool und wenn ihr
ideen habt können
in die kommentare sparen einer liegt
noch kein team ist besser denn ich
schätze mal wird jetzt bei unserer basin
also aufpassen nicht runterfallen ja
erst bei unserer ersten service aber ich
denke mal wir kriegen die safe kriegen
wir die wir müssen ja nicht nur auf
distanz irgendwie ein bisschen kaputt
schießen
er hat geehrt glaube ich eine spitzhacke
dabei und verzweifelter gerade parlament
stone ich lasse den kriegst du ihn tot
ich habe ihn damit direkt an ich wollte
herbst hat ein bisschen abwarten das
sieht man auch um eine aufnahme weil ich
dachte er hätte nicht mal rüstung aber
der war völlig rip deswegen hat ja noch
ein bisschen angst also um das ganze
zusammen zu fassen ist es ist natürlich
geil dass er so etwas wollt aber das
braucht natürlich lange um zu planen und
denke auch dass die leute die zurzeit
minecraft auch machen sind zurzeit ja
auch noch am plan von einem neuen
projekt was nur die machen also dass es
nur von denen die auch machen aber es
gibt natürlich noch ganz viele andere
sachen aber ich was mich angeht hat auch
wieder ganz ganz viele sachen für meinen
kanal geplant
da auch ein neues format was gerade noch
eine entwicklung ist damit habe ich mit
max schon ein bisschen drüber geredet
jetzt aber das müssen dann muss ich noch
gucken und wie das alles wird und dann
würde ich einfach sagen ihr könnt ihr
was in die kommentare schreiben was ihr
davon haltet wir das projekt besser
machen würde was er sich am meisten
wünschen würde
und da will ich sagen praxis in der
beschreibung da könnt ihr auch mal bei
100.000 abonnenten special vorbeigucken
wenn es euch gefallen könnte eine
bewertung lassen und dann sehen wir uns
in der nächsten folge wieder und ja
sonst wollte ich eigentlich mehr etwas
schreiben kommentare